the circulation team takes it from there
and the turnaround time where we have to
get this done is relatively slow it's a
few hours usually it depends on the
distributor so this isn't a really
pressing real time kind of problem but
it does have to be robust because in the
end we do end up controlling a lot of a
lot of stores and a lot of sales now
this is a problem that has existed at
the time any newspaper and probably many
other types of companies for a really
long time so we're not starting from
scratch here we're replacing an existing
algorithm but the existing algorithm
it's very heuristics based it's very
manually tuned so roughly what it has
been doing is taking for a type of store
for a store the highest sales from
recent weeks in that store then
multiplying it by a number a which is
probably a little bit more than one and
then adding a number B which might be a
copy or a few copies and a nested number
of newspapers that you want to send next
week and the trouble from our
perspective is that a and B are really
hand-tuned and they're hand-tuned by
type of store maybe by the location by
any number of things based on the
historical experience of the people
involved in this project and also the
code for this is interspersed among many
many lines of COBOL and that COBOL code
doesn't just do this it does many other
things and it's not at all modular so
it's really hard to keep track of what
exactly is going on so normally in talks
these days we don't get to use Joe COBOL
code you had some COBOL code part of it
but this is what we were trying to sift
through to see if we could use what they
were doing as a starting point for kind
of learnings of the types of things we
should look at and in the end we kind of
gave up part of the reason that the
Print Group wanted us involved in this
project was because this code is very
difficult to modify very difficult to
comprehend and to add extra information
into that would be helpful in modeling
but isn't currently there it's also a
very classical data science
problem of time series modeling and so
this was a really good project for us to
get involved in as part of integrating
data science into the New York Times in
terms of algorithms Fitness the problem
is separable really into two parts the
first question is regarding predictions
of demand given previous sales in
certain stores and certainties how many
papers do we think will sell in a given
you know next Thursday or something but
then once we know that there's the
second part which is if we think four
papers will sell next Thursday how many
should we really deliver and if we think
that we're really sure that four papers
are gonna sell but there's always some
sort of uncertainty associated with our
demand prediction and since we make a
profit on the papers usually pays for us
to send some extras it's in case the
noise fluctuates up and we get an extra
sale that makes it worth it to err on
the side of extra delivery so the policy
function determines exactly how many we
should send based on our predictions so
the first type of algorithm that we used
for this problem was just a classic auto
regressive like one time series model
this is for the prediction half of the
problem to say how many takers do we
think will sell given historical sales
and so here you have X at time T would
be the demand for a newspaper at time T
you can parameterize it by a constant C
plus Phi times the most recent sale you
know the sales at times t minus one
which in our case would be like a week
ago
and then plus some noise epsilon so
basically today's sale is a linear
function of last week's tend to make one
model to her store per day of the week
this is because the days of the week
kind of behave differently and on a
store basis it changes
for example the Sunday paper is really
large and really expensive compared to
weekdays and so that's a significant
difference in both sales behavior and in
profit behavior also some of the stores
are only open on weekdays or weekends
etc or they have different traffic
patterns during the weekdays we use
about a year's worth of data to fit
further parameters C and Phi and then
hyper parameters for the model like the
training window of around a year or what
lag to use for the auto regressive model
were chosen via cross-validation when we
were developing this model in the first
place already I meant to say that this
was really developed by Dale Kim there's
no longer at the times but I want to
call out the people who actually built
this stuff since there have been a
number of us who have worked on this
project for the policy function for this
you know given the demand that the AR
model for days how many should we
actually send we're just using the C of
the demand so that we know we're always
sending at least as many newspapers as
we think will so there's also this
factor that we called the bump which is
that if there have been recent sellouts
in the data just send an extra on top of
what we would otherwise send and this is
a kind of manual brute-force attempt at
addressing the fact that our data are
actually censored because if they're
sellouts then we don't know what the
demand actually was all we know is that
the demand was at least how many as we
delivered so by just gradually bumping
up the number we're delivering in case
of sellouts we're slowly reducing that
censoring in the data set in terms of
implementation this was all written in
Python the AR model is in stats models
and it was all written in a single
script we also had on a local server a
flask at hosting matplotlib PNG is that
monitored the drawers in the sandwich
just to make sure that everything was
going rather smoothly over time the
weekly process was run by a cron job on
that server and this this worked
but it wasn't the greatest like data
engineering setup we didn't have any
separate dev or prod environments you
know deploying the code involved just
like tp'ing it from your laptop of to
the server so it ended up being rather
fragile and we wanted to improve the
data engineering as well as the
algorithms but we're still in the
algorithm section for now the second and
this is actually the main algorithm that
we're still using is Hassan regression
and this was developed by doing open and
in many ways it's similar to the AR
model in that today's sale is a linear
function of previous sales per store per
day of the week we also added a
dependence on sales not just last week
but also fifty two weeks ago in case
there's some seasonality to be able to
capture a little bit of that in the
model again we use about a little more
than years worth of data to fit the
model parameters but there are two main
improvements between this model compared
to the arrow model and the first one is
that we're assuming that the sales are
drawn from openness on distribution
rather than on a Gaussian one and so
this plot shows the difference in that
they're both distributions the blue is
Poisson and the green is Gaussian and
they both have expected value of one so
this is what you expect for it to sell
one newspaper the probability
distribution you can see or actually
ending up selling three or four
newspapers is way higher in the case of
the Poisson distribution than in the
normal distribution and so this means
that if you have some noisy data this
makes a really significant difference in
the results in terms of understanding
the expected value of your sales the
other improvement here compared to the
AR is that we are now considering
sellouts as part of the likelihood
function in the minima
I wanted to go into that in a little
more detail the equation on the top is
just the definition of the Poisson
probability distribution here lambda is
the Poisson parameter which tells you
the expected sales and Z is the demand
that actually happens in the story for
newspapers so Z is the Poisson
distributed latent variable described by
the Pusan Perimeter expected sales
lambda now lambda is what we're trying
to figure out here the expected sales
that are the expected demand that we're
trying to fit for it so we want to
parameterize this in terms of our meters
and so that's what we're doing here
where you have lambda parameter eyes in
terms of weights theta and features X
and the feature is X since we're doing a
time series it's just previous since
like last week last year and the theta
are the parameters that were fitting for
in the minimization now we need to
understand what the probability
distribution of our data is and so that
is the probability of the papers that we
see thought given the papers that we
deliver and then this lambda expected
demand so what your first line is doing
really on the right hand side is just
putting in Z the observed demand and
marginalizing over it but then you can
separate this into two terms where it
equals the sum over the observed true
demand Z of the probability of papers
bought B given that demand C and the
number we delivered D times the
probability of the demand given lambda
and the reason to do this is because
that second part the probability of the
demand versus lambda is just the Poisson
distribution that was defined on the
previous slide so we know what that is
by our assumption that this is a Poisson
distribute
so then we just need to look at what the
first chart is and this is where the
sellouts come in you have on the third
line that the probability of the papers
bought the number of papers bought given
the demand and the papers we send is in
the case where the demand is less than
what we send we know that the number of
papers bought is just equal to the
demand however if the demand is larger
than what we sent all we know is that
the number of papers bought is equal to
the number that we sent so we don't
really know what the demand is so if we
plug in these two Delta functions into
the term above you get the line at the
bottom where now that sum is just
separated into two terms where you're
considering the probability one piece in
cases where you're delivering enough
sand so you can see what the demand is
and then the second term regarding some
of us so this is the probability then
that we put into the maximum likelihood
estimation and to do the fit for lambda
and therefore actually fit what the
parameters theta
so that is how we do the predictions
half of the Poisson regression and then
given that information and the fitted
Thetas we can get our projected demand
in a store for whatever given day the
next piece is what to do in terms of how
many newspapers to actually send the
policy function and it turns out that
this is actually a well known problem in
optimization circles and it's called the
news vendor algorithm and basically what
you're doing is just optimizing for
profit and this is an analytical
solution so we don't need to do any kind
of machine learning in this part at all
if you want to optimize for profit we
define profit simply just as the price
of the newspaper times how many are sold
minus the cost for us to get the
newspaper out there times how many we
sent never actually told you that the
jargony term for how many papers you
deliver is called draw so I might have
been saying draw here and there but that
is what I'm referring to so if you want
to maximize the profit if you just take
this take the derivative of it set to
zero
it implies that the probability that the
actual demand is less than or equal to
what you send is just equal to the price
of the paper
- our costs over the price of the paper
this means that the optimal draw that we
want to send is the smallest integer
such that that probability is greater
than or equal to the price minus cost of
our price and so we know pretty much
everything in this equation the
probability is Poisson distributed so
that's fine we know the price in the
cost structure and Z is the demand
prediction from the previous step so we
can just sweep through possible values
of how many newspapers when you want to
deliver deep and find the one who
satisfies each constraint and then that
is the optimal number that we want to
send so that's what we do
so once we had written this fancier
algorithm we wanted to also upgrade our
code a bit to make it easier to develop
more algorithms in the future and so we
made this more object-oriented we made a
model class that could be inherited that
basically took the form of scikit-learn
classes with query fit and predict but
also with the policy function and we
also extracted some common library code
that we expected
although the different models would
probably want to use so now that we had
a couple different algorithms and we
also wanted to compare not just between
them but between us and the previous the
original algorithm which we tend to call
BAU business-as-usual we wanted to run
some experiments so the first thing that
we needed to do in running these
experiments is figure out treatment and
control groups of stores so this is a
cool project because you can actually
deploy different algorithms predictions
in actually different physical stores
and see what happens cross your fingers
and hope that you don't take the New
York Times the matching group the
matching technique that we use between
the treatment control stories is very
straightforward all we wanted to do is
make sure that we were matching pairwise
stores with similar sales history
however we also ended up realizing that
we needed to do a number of sort of
trial and error checks to make sure that
the basically the domain knowledge
associated with the problem was
sufficiently applied to this matching
for example not all the stores sell
papers on the weekends so we need to
make sure that we weren't pairing the
seven-day store with a five-day store or
some stores have higher costs than the
others because some print sites are more
expensive than others so we had to make
sure that our pairings had similar cost
structure you know things like that we
also needed to build some dashboards to
be able to visualize how the experiments
were going and so this is a screenshot
from one that we're actually deprecating
we're replacing it with an updated
version but it will show basically the
same
basic information here the left and
right columns show the Monday through
Saturday on the left and Sunday on the
right and we tend to look at Sunday
differently just because the costs are
so different the newspaper is different
a lot of people only buy the Sunday
paper so we tend to look at it as kind
of a different product the top two plots
show profit compared to the BAU
algorithm and actually this whole
screenshot is for the first algorithm
that we tried the auto regressive model
I erased all the numbers from the y-axis
of these plots so that you can't see how
much money we made but the the profit is
bigger than zero so we did definitely do
better than the VIU algorithm so that
was great the bottom two plots show how
many newspapers we sent the drawers and
how many were sold and the darker colors
are a treatment group the lighter colors
are the control group the BAU original
algorithm and so here you can see what
the algorithm is doing I mean it thinks
that we were sending way too many extra
papers and it cut down hugely into the
numbers that we sent saving a lot of
money in printing costs and distribution
costs this also has a minimal but
significant effect on the sales in that
on average we were still needing demand
but in cases where the demand was much
higher than expected there were more
sellouts and so you can see that our
algorithm was actually selling less than
the control by it however that eating
into the sales didn't come at such an
expensive profit such that you know
we're still winning significantly on
profit so we looked at these results and
we thought they were good you know we're
making money so we went back to the
Print Group or stakeholders in the
project and we're like check it out
we're making all this money and they
weren't actually very happy about this
because this profit was coming at the
expense of this loss in sales
and at this point we really internalized
the fact that the sales matter more than
just the money to the company the
circulation numbers matter for example
for the advertising department and it's
really hard to quantify the value to the
other parts of the company of these
sales numbers so this kind of put us in
a bit of a bind because we were still
wanting to optimize for profit but but
don't lose too many sales and but they
won't define how many sales are too many
sales and so what are you supposed to do
but this turns out to be a really good
case for constrained optimization and so
what we did let's say we need to modify
the algorithms moment what we did was
modify our use of the news vendor policy
function because we no longer want to
optimize really for profit but we want
to do is maximize profit but also put
some weight on the sales numbers and so
what you do is you introduce this lambda
Lagrange multiplier which is a negative
number so you're maximizing profit plus
some number times sales so if you put
this into the equations from the slide a
few slides ago with the same kind of
Matt you just maximize that you find
that the optimal draw which is the case
where the probability of the demand
being less than or equal to the job is
greater than price minus lambda minus
cost over price minus lambda which is
the same functional form as we had
before but just effectively increasing
the sales price by negative lambda so
this makes it worth sending extra papers
because it's as if whenever anybody buys
a paper it gives the times a little
extra money on top of what the sales
price actually is
the obvious question at this point is
what should we put his lambda because
it's an entirely tunable parameter and
we decided to leave this up to the
stakeholders we made a plot for them
that looked something like this
the y-axis shows how much extra money
that our algorithm will make compared to
what they're already doing and the
x-axis shows how many sales will make
compared to what they're already doing
and so you can see that we can make a
lot of money if we are selling
significantly less and then as we bump
up the sales more and more we
progressively lose profit hmm was there
any interesting going even in opposite
direction seeing it buy so over
supplying you increase sales no because
it seemed that what they were already
doing in the market was flooding the
market and it was almost never selling
out so this is actually an interesting
question because in the example that I'm
showing you yes however this is just for
one distributor and in other markets
that hasn't been true we have seen that
we need to go deliver more than they've
delivered and then make up for some
opportunity so it does go both ways but
this one was the first one that we did
and it's the largest one that we did so
is still the most common case for us so
we expected them to look at this plot
and say okay you know let's do it
somewhere around this like inflection
point where you're still making pretty
much all the money and but you're not
like wasting sales but that's not at all
what happened they came back and said oh
let's do something around here where
we're still making profit over what they
were doing before but putting much more
attention on the sales then we just
offhand expected and so we realized that
this tunable knob is really handy in
this project because
we don't have to as the data science
team understand all of the business
considerations that go into the print
circulation group we can leave that up
to them and at the same time it gives
them some level of control and insight
into our algorithms which makes them
more comfortable working with us so that
it's not so much like giving up all
control of their business to some kind
of black box so in the end we ran a lot
of experiments some of them they are
based most of them was on taste but with
different values of this lambda
parameter and we could show them just
model comparison bar charts where the
green here like each one of these
letters is a different algorithm or a
different variant of the algorithm the
green is how much money we're making
versus their BAU algorithm the red is
how many sales we're selling compared to
the BAU algorithm so you can see it
varies from like losing a bunch to being
eaten and so we showed this Emily said
we said which one should we put in
production and they chose death okay so
finally I wanted to go over the app
architecture a little bit a couple of
years ago the near times made a
significant effort to move over to the
Google cloud platform which has been
wonderful and as part of this process we
decided to reform this onto Google cloud
as well and using mainly App Engine and
App Engine flex so there are a few
different components to this one of them
is the web UI which is run on App Engine
standard the reporting and predictions
calculations are all run on App Engine
flex because at least at the time you
couldn't run stuff like pandas and Syfy
on App Engine standard so you needed
something more
where you could have your own custom
containers on it I keep all our data in
various places mostly bigquery but also
cloud storage cause sequel also a little
bit of datastore for hosting the sales
data and also config information and
this is all deployed via drone so it's
pretty straightforward for the appengine
standard you hook it up from like github
commits and tags to map engine deploy
for App Engine flex it's a little more
involved because you need to build your
own container and then deploy that to
that bench in Flex the weekly process is
very similar to what I showed before but
just for comparison see again there's a
weekly con job Perkin distributor that's
hosted on the App Engine standard
instance but it takes advantage of task
queue tasks which is very handy because
it involves like retrying of the tasks
and things like this basically what the
con job kicks off is a process to look
for data on the FTP server because we
don't want to we don't know exactly when
it's gonna show up we just know that it
tends to show up at a certain time and
we don't want to wait super long to the
last possible instant when it might show
up to start looking so the task looks
for the data if it's not there it fails
the task queue will take over the job of
retrying this process every n minutes or
whatever you set it to for as long as
you want
and until it's been some sort of cut up
cut off time that you can set at which
point it'll fail permanently and then
you can deal with the consequences of
the data never showing up in whatever
weight that you want logs for the
project or sent to stackdriver and that
sends us emails if there are errors in
the process but mainly we keep track of
this for slack because so I can Python
have a very easy integration and so we
output a lot of quality checks and
progress messages to a slack channel
devoted for these logs and I don't know
if you can read this or not it's just a
screenshot of it telling us that the
reporting is done the validation of the
data is done with links to the UI so you
can see
what's going on the reporting process
just a lot of calculations of
aggregations just to make sure that the
experiments are going well and so that
we can see how the experiments are going
traditionally we've been doing this in a
lot of pandas in that Benjen flex
instances however we've been really
moving it to bigquery because it's a lot
easier for bigquery to handle things
like parallelization and memory rather
than us worrying about like running out
of memory on our engine Flex instance if
there's too much data we also run
statistical tests on the data quality to
make sure that what we're getting in as
sales data is somewhat consistent with
historical data and if that's not true
then it raises all sorts of warnings in
our slack channel we save all the data
back to bigquery and then also mirror it
in cloud sequel server we can use that
for filtering in real time on the front
end DUI the predictions process is very
similar these data from bigquery
it runs the predictions with a lot of
sigh pie and some scikit-learn on then
coming up with the predicted number of
deliveries for next week
which it saves back to Google Cloud
Storage we also run validation tests on
this to make sure that the predictions
that we're coming up with are not very
different from what we came up with last
week and if they are it again raises a
lot of messages in our slack Channel and
then stops the process so we don't
submit predictions that look crazy but
assuming that passed the validation
checks then the last step is just a copy
the data or the predictions up to the
FTP site where the circulation team
picks it up from there so that's sort of
the project from beginning to end I
think it's a really interesting project
to work on because it has a lot of
different components that you run into
in data science projects in general for
example we did have to do some custom
modeling and fancy math with the
algorithms to make sure that what we
were solving for was
really appropriate to the domain
knowledge and the way the problem was
working this was a cool opportunity to
do a bunch of data engineering and rhe
platform everything with up-to-date
tools I like the experiments that we can
run in this project because you can
really measure how much money you're
making and that's very satisfying
because often with other projects we
were looking at like click-through rate
or something which is much
I mean it's related to the bottom line
but you have to make a lot of
assumptions and how it's related to the
bottom line so this is kind of fun as a
change and then finally communication
was a really big part of this project
because you know as data scientists
optimizing our profit we thought we were
doing a very good job and then we only
really learned from sitting down with
our print partners and talking with them
that like our initial algorithms didn't
actually outperform the original BAU
algorithm by the standards of everybody
involved and so only after like sussing
out with him what was important could we
figure out how to like fold not just
their quantitative concerns but also
their qualitative concerns into our
algorithms so that the project was a
success for the whole team
[Applause]
for the prediction test seems like a
really good fit for babies in regression
because you could tie all the
regressions together and get yeah we
have heard a few different things that I
don't believe we've tried a Bayesian
regression but it would give assuming
the fits accurate like it would give a
much better estimate of the errors then
which would help that's definitely true
what we have seen is that in the second
part of the problem of policy function
where we're assuming that the
uncertainty on ur parameter on the final
prediction is is Poisson but that's a
fairly accurate assumption given the
data that we see so I'm not sure how
much difference it would make in
practice yeah it would in the
minimization part and nobody interesting
to see how then the errors that you get
match with the errors that we were
sitting right with times regressions
together better accuracy yeah yeah we
have tried hierarchical modeling of the
stores so that we're not modeling each
of them separately which didn't give us
as much lift as we expected so we've
gone a little bit down that route but it
would be interesting to go further
but he said that you have a different
model for each distributor we actually
have a different model for you to store
well we're not regulating them all but
ultimately when we take over the
universe yes they're reset every week
yeah I mean they're pretty small models
and that there are only a few features
47,000 small models we do have to pay
attention to that and make sure we don't
develop anything too sophisticated so
that we can't turn it around in time no
that's actually something that that is
not a use case for our algorithm we're
doing just day-to-day normal operations
if something is happening that's special
then human beings just override us
because there's just not enough
historical data of the you know the the
human knowledge about that is much
better than what they they override us
then new stores they don't get to us
immediately they have a policy where
it's like I think five weeks they just
send like five papers or something or I
forget what the number is that they set
a number depending on something and then
only once we have that like intro
training set then regulate that's
actually the same policy that they
always had they've always given
everything a flat said at the beginning
and then re-evaluated each one is one
experiment or whatever
something like the Delphian toes these
are the new strippers with deliver so
many thumbs straight yeah I mean but we
but we give back is for every store ID
for every day of the week this is the
number you want to send and really on
the low-level execution side I don't
know how it works from there on out um
and they they have an agreement for
their distributors on the store by store
level to as much as possible so have you
ever tried that we've tried but we
didn't find any real groupings of the
stores that added enough like that
helped enough in reducing the noise
compared to the precision we'll be
losing them together ok it's sort of
similar level results we've wanted to
but we have to give the predictions kind
of for in advance so like on a Wednesday
say like so today we'll give predictions
for next Monday through next Saturday
and the weather forecast like isn't that
great at that time out and then also it
doesn't match the training data because
our training data will be like hindsight
perfect so you know it's not something
that I think is super practical but it's
something we've always wanted to do
because we know that it should make a
difference plan to make it like an API
or something as opposed to this no
because the FTP push method is what the
parent people want
I think API might be a little
plus useful for them I mean we've talked
about like them taking it from google
cloud storage or whatever but but this
works so because after this handoff they
take it they like ingest it into their
mainframe so you were like inserting
ourselves system rather than the other
way around is there when you completed
the profit is it sort of the generic
profit per paper averaged over all of
the 47,000 stores or is it somehow
specific because obviously some places
are further from the critical planets or
you know I'll get tickets for very much
like that yeah I mean we had it down to
basically the profits are different by
print site because they the deals that
the paper has but a different print
sites are different but the delivery
cost I think is kind of flat per core
distributor so it's like kind of a
middling level of granularity
I think everybody has done the question
yeah I'll be around
[Applause]